it's October 1997 and it's almost
Halloween teen dream jennifer Love
Hewitt is starring as Julie James in the
now classic I know what you did last
summer Universal Studios in Hollywood
just launched Halloween Horror Nights
and the top-selling costume was Batman
no thanks to George Clooney's ill-fated
portrayal in the film Batman and Robin
his words not ours
I wasn't good in it it wasn't a good
film it's the season of scary and that
might have included scary books and
movies like these you know to help you
get into the Halloween spirit
[Applause]
[Music]
the fall Book Fair got you hooked on RL
Stein here the new book out called
werewolf skin and you're feeling brave
enough to read it all ages like a good
scary story
hi I'm RL Stein I write the Goosebumps
books the second best-selling book
series in history what was the first
[Music]
obviously Harry Potter I didn't want to
do goosebumps but he did he went out and
they just sat on the shelf did himself
and if something happened it's a mystery
kids discovered it somehow it was the
book fair we were selling four million
Goosebumps books a month we love the
night on the Halloween movie spectrum
there are lots of classics but our heart
is loyal to what hocus pocus this is
doug jones the nfinity man from the
shape of water the pale man from Pan's
Labyrinth hushed in Buffy the Vampire
Slayer and Billy butch ursin in hocus
pocus I was a zombie before zombies were
cool okay he was comedic and floppy and
goofy but kind of handsome I'm not
handsome by the makeup made me answer I
loved being something otherworldly in a
happy light-hearted happy ending kind of
story and that's rare
stories for the past three decades scary
stories to tell in the dark has been
challenged and even banned from some
schools and libraries across the u.s.
the drawings were just too scary so we
tried to talk to Steven Kemal the
illustrator but he doesn't do interviews
however in our pile of research we found
this so this his bread helpless he is
also an illustrator
you might recognize his work from a
series of unfortunate events but as we
found out he also had this other gig he
realest rated scary stories when Harper
College came to me they asked me to
really illustrate those books I never
imagined that I would upset anybody but
it did as it turns out Stephen Amell
illustrations came with a pretty serious
fan club I had great respect of the
original illustration but I love a good
scary story so around 100 new
illustrations later we now have a less
scary but still fabulous scary stories
to tell in the dark so there you have it
your Halloween entertainment and some of
the people behind it in 1997
[Music]
[Laughter]
you